Traductor: Denise RQ
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
Para el microscópico gusano
de laboratorio, C. elegans
la vida solo consta de
pocas semanas en la Tierra.
Compara esto con la vida de una tortuga
que puede llegar a tener más de 100 años.
Los ratones y las ratas cierran su ciclo
de vida después de solo cuatro años
mientras que para la ballena boreal,
el mamífero terrestre más longevo,
la muerte llega después de 200 años.
Como la mayoría de los seres vivos,
los animales se deterioran gradualmente
una vez alcanzada la madurez sexual
en un proceso llamado envejecimiento.
Pero ¿qué significa envejecer realmente?
Los mecanismos detrás de este proceso
son variados y complicados,
pero en última instancia, las causas son
la muerte celular y la disfunción.
Cuando somos jóvenes,
regeneramos células constantemente
reemplazando las células muertas
o las que están muriendo.
Pero a medida que envejecemos,
este proceso se ralentiza.
Además, las células más viejas no operan
tan bien como las más jóvenes.
Eso hace que nuestros
cuerpos entren en declive,
lo que finalmente trae
enfermedades y la muerte.
Pero si eso es sistemáticamente cierto,
¿por qué la enorme variación
en los patrones de envejecimiento
y expectativas de vida en el reino animal?
La respuesta se debe a varios factores
que incluyen el medio ambiente
y el tamaño corporal.
Estos pueden crear inmensas presiones
evolutivas en la adaptación animal,
que a su vez generan diferentes procesos
de envejecimiento en cada especie.
Tomemos las profundidades heladas
de los océanos Atlántico y Ártico,
donde los tiburones de Groenlandia
pueden vivir hasta más de 400 años,
y la almeja de Islandia conocida
como quahog puede vivir hasta 500 años.
Tal vez el más impresionante entre
estos habitantes oceánicos ancestrales
es la esponja vítrea antártica
que puede sobrevivir más
de 10 000 años en aguas gélidas.
En tales ambientes fríos, los latidos
y los niveles metabólicos disminuyen.
Los investigadores teorizan
que esto también causa
una ralentización del envejecimiento.
De esta manera, el entorno
influye en la longevidad.
Cuando se trata de tamaño, se da el caso
de que a menudo, pero no siempre,
las especies más grandes tienen
mayor expectativa de vida que las demás.
Por ejemplo, un elefante o una ballena
vivirá mucho más tiempo
que un ratón, rata terrestre o acuatica,
que a su vez viven más años
que las moscas y gusanos.
Algunos animales pequeños,
como los gusanos y las moscas,
están limitados también
por la mecánica de su división celular
cuyas células no se dividen
o se reemplazan cuando están dañadas.
de modo que sus cuerpos
caducan más rápidamente.
Y el tamaño es un mecanismo evolutivo
poderoso en los animales.
Las criaturas más pequeñas son
más vulnerables a los depredadores.
Un ratón, por ejemplo, difícilmente
sobrevivirá más de 1 año en la naturaleza.
Por lo tanto, ha evolucionado
para crecer y reproducir más rápidamente,
como un mecanismo de defensa evolutiva
contra su corta expectativa de vida.
Por otro lado, los animales más grandes
se enfrentan mejor a los depredadores,
por lo tanto tienen la ventaja del tiempo
para alcanzar tamaños más grandes
y reproducirse varias veces
durante sus vidas.
Las excepciones a la regla
de tamaño incluyen
murciélagos, pájaros, topos y tortugas,
pero en cada caso, estos animales
tienen otras adaptaciones
que les permiten escapar
de los depredadores.
Pero también hay casos en los que
animales con características similares
como el tamaño y el hábitat,
envejecen a ritmos
completamente diferentes.
En estos casos, diferencias genéticas
cómo el tipo de respuesta
a amenazas de cada organismo
a menudo explica
dichas discrepancias en la longevidad.
Así que es la combinación
de todos estos factores
que actúan de maneras diferentes
en diferentes animales
lo que explica la variabilidad
que vemos en el reino animal.
¿Y en nuestro caso?
Los seres humanos actualmente tienen
una expectativa media de vida de 71 años,
Lo que significa que no somos ni de cerca
los habitantes más longevos de la Tierra.
Pero somos muy buenos en aumentar
nuestra esperanza de vida.
A principios del siglo XX, vivíamos
en promedio solo 50 años.
Desde entonces, hemos
aprendido a adaptarnos
controlando muchos de los factores
que causan la muerte,
como la exposición
ambiental y la nutrición.
Esto y otros aumentos
en la esperanza de vida
demuestran que probablemente
somos la única especie terrestre
capaz de tener el control
sobre nuestro destino natural.